- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La séance est
ouverte.
Avant de commencer, je voudrais
rendre hommage à Léon Gautier.
Léon Gautier avait 17 ans
lorsqu'il se rallia au général de
Gaulle.
Il avait 20 ans lorsqu'il
rejoignit les 176 autres Français
du commando Kieffer.
21 ans à peine lorsqu'il débarqua
sur les rivages de Normandie le 6
juin 1944.
Il incarnait une jeunesse
exemplaire qui, armée de son seul
courage et de son sens du devoir,
se mit au service d'une cause
qu'il jugeait supérieure à sa
propre vie, celle de la paix.
Il s'engagea pour défendre notre
pays et ses citoyens par amour de
la patrie et fit preuve d'un
dévouement sans faille au service
des valeurs de liberté, d'égalité
et de fraternité.
C'est à la jeunesse que Léon
Gautier, il y a 100 ans encore,
s'adressait en ambassadeur de la
paix.
Comme l'a rappelé Christophe
Blanchet, député du Calvados qui
l'a bien connu, il était "fier et
heureux", chaque 6 juin, de
remettre aux militaires leur béret
pour leur engagement.
On sentait dans son regard la
douleur d'un ami tombé ce jour-là.
Puisse son souvenir continuer à
inspirer les nouvelles
générations.
Au nom de l'Assemblée nationale,
j'adresse nos plus sincères
condoléances à sa famille et à ses
proches.
En hommage à Léon Gautier, à son
amour de la France, à son courage
de jeune homme, à sa sagesse de
vétéran, je vous demande de bien
vouloir observer une minute de
silence.
Je vous remercie.
L'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au gouvernement.
Je voudrais, avant de donner la
parole à notre premier orateur,
saluer le retour parmi nous de
madame Elisa Révah, qui est une
agente de l'Assemblée nationale
qui, devant la plupart d'entre
vous, a eu un malaise et qui a
recouvré la santé.
Bienvenue à vous, madame.
Applaudissements
Merci beaucoup, mes chers
collègues.
La parole est à madame la
présidente Mathilde Panot pour le
groupe La France Insoumise.
- Mathilde Panot: Nahel, 17 ans,
est mort abattu par un policier.
15 jours avant, une autre personne
est décédée dans des circonstances
atroces.
Vous n'avez donné aucune solution
politique pour résoudre de tels
problèmes.
Comment un jeune de 17 ans peut-il
être tué en République française?
Pourquoi 16 personnes ont-elles
trouvé la mort en 10 ans pour
refus d'obtempérer?
Combien d'autres Nahel n'ont pas
été filmés?
Pour justifier l'inaction, vous
versez dans le déni.
Vous avez dit hier que les émeutes
que connaît le pays n'ont rien à
voir avec la mort de Nahel.
Vous voulez faire peser sur nous
la responsabilité de la colère
quand elle prend racine dans un
meurtre odieux.
Madame la Première ministre, ni
les interpellations, ni la
répression ne viendront tarir la
soif de justice de la jeunesse.
Seule une réponse politique est de
nature à apaiser durablement le
pays.
Le retour au calme ne se décrète
pas, il se construit.
Quand Alliance Police et l'UNSA
parlent de "rentrer en guerre
contre des nuisibles", ils ne
parlent plus la langue de la
République.
Voici ce qui devrait interpeller
votre gouvernement.
Regardez la situation en face,
madame la Première ministre.
Il faut un débat à l'Assemblée
nationale.
Quand prendrez-vous au sérieux nos
propositions?
Etes-vous favorable à l'abrogation
du permis de tuer de la loi
Cazeneuve qui a provoqué
l'explosion du nombre de morts en
cas de refus d'obtempérer?
Allez-vous créer un comité vérité
et justice pour faire la
transparence sur les cas de
violences policières?
Allez-vous créer un fonds
d'indemnisation pour les
commerçants et collectivités
victimes des événements de cette
semaine?
Comptez-vous allonger la formation
des policiers?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, madame
la présidente Panot.
Huées et applaudissements
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
Un peu de silence, s'il vous
plaît.
Madame la Première ministre, vous
avez la parole.
- Elisabeth Borne: Madame la
présidente Mathilde Panot, comme
de nombreux Français, j'ai été
émue et choquée par la mort d'un
jeune de 17 ans la semaine
dernière à Nanterre.
Je l'ai dit au Sénat très
clairement dès mercredi dernier.
Le gouvernement a fait preuve de
la plus grande transparence dans
cette affaire et la justice
établira toute la vérité.
Mais, madame la présidente Panot,
dans un moment comme celui que
nous traversons, nous devons
regarder la réalité en face.
Depuis une semaine, face aux
violences qui ont éclaté, je
cherche vos condamnations et
j'entends des excuses.
Avec votre parti, vous
instrumentalisez un drame.
Vous refusez de condamner
clairement les violences, vous
refusez d'appeler au calme alors
que nos policiers et nos gendarmes
luttent pour préserver l'ordre
républicain, alors que des
sapeurs-pompiers combattent des
incendies, alors que des maires
sont aux côtés des habitants et
sont la cible de violence.
Des mairies et des écoles sont
incendiées, des magasins pillés,
des élus et leurs familles
attaqués, et vous cherchez des
coupables partout, dans toutes nos
institutions républicaines, sauf
chez les auteurs de violence.
Vous auriez pu, comme vos alliés
de la NUPES, exprimer votre
émotion à la suite de la mort d'un
jeune de 17 ans, demander justice
et appeler sans ambiguïté au
retour au calme, mais vous et les
autres parlementaires insoumis
avez choisi un autre chemin, celui
de l'outrance, de la brutalité
verbale et de l'excuse constante
de la violence.
Madame la présidente Panot, quand
vos députés rejettent tout appel
au calme, vous sortez du champ
républicain.
Applaudissements
...
Quand une de vos députées affirme
que la force justifie les moyens,
vous sortez du champ républicain.
Quand votre leader parle de permis
de tuer pour les policiers, de
peine de mort pour les jeunes des
quartiers et nous traite de chiens
de garde, vous sortez du champ
républicain.
Les violences, madame la
présidente Panot, rien ne peut les
excuser.
Pendant que vous jetez de l'huile
sur le feu, pendant que vous
donnez des excuses aux
délinquants, nous nous sommes
engagés pour rétablir l'ordre
républicain.
Je vous remercie.
...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, madame la Première
ministre.
La parole est au président Marleix
pour le groupe Les Républicains.
- Olivier Marleix: Depuis
plusieurs jours, des émeutiers ont
semé le chaos dans notre pays.
Au nom des députés Les
Républicains, nous donnons notre
soutien à ces milliers de
commerçants dont les magasins ont
été pillés.
Je veux dire notre soutien à ces
milliers de Français dont les
véhicules ont été incendiés.
Je veux dire notre soutien aux
maires qui ont été pris pour
cibles, notamment à Vincent
Jeanbrun et sa famille,
odieusement attaqués à leur
domicile.
Et je veux dire notre immense
reconnaissance envers les forces
de sécurité, policiers et
gendarmes, policiers municipaux,
sapeurs-pompiers, et je pense au
caporal-chef Damelincourt.
Leur extraordinaire sang-froid est
à saluer.
Une réponse exemplaire permettra
d'endiguer la violence.
Je vous demande, madame la
Première ministre, de publier
chaque semaine l'activité de la
justice, département par
département.
Combien de personnes interpellées,
combien de personnes déférées à la
justice, combien de personnes
condamnées.
Le temps des excuses, le temps des
sursis, le temps de l'impunité est
révolu.
Pour les mineurs, notre Code pénal
prévoit que les parents des
délinquants puissent être
condamnés.
Quand on laisse un enfant de 14 ou
15 ans dehors à 2h du matin par
une nuit d'émeutes, on doit avoir
sa responsabilité engagée.
C'est la loi.
Appliquez-la.
Je vous demande de mobiliser ce
qu'il faudra de magistrats
honoraires ou de magistrats à
titre temporaire pour juger toutes
ces affaires dans les 100 jours.
Ne pas punir serait une injure
pour nos forces de l'ordre.
Ne pas punir, ce serait ne pas
comprendre la gravité de la menace
pour la France.
Ce serait empêcher de reconstruire
la concorde dans notre pays.
Il faut un changement de cap.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le président.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Monsieur le
président Olivier Marleix, depuis
que des violences inadmissibles
ont éclaté, nous avons travaillé
sans relâche au maintien de
l'ordre républicain sur tout le
territoire.
Depuis le début des violences,
près de 4000 personnes ont été
interpellées.
Le garde des Sceaux a transmis une
circulaire de politique pénale aux
parquets généraux, leur demandant
une réponse rapide, ferme et
systématique pour tous les
auteurs.
Je vous confirme que le garde des
Sceaux demande notamment que des
sanctions pénales puissent être
prononcées pour les parents qui
laissent leurs enfants de 12 à 14
ans traîner le soir, mettre le feu
à nos mairies, à nos
commissariats.
Au total, hier soir, près de 700
personnes ont été déférées.
Près de 800 gardes à vue ont eu
lieu.
La réponse pénale est en cours.
Des peines lourdes ont été
prononcées, notamment de la prison
ferme avec mandat de dépôt.
D'ores et déjà, 350 personnes sont
placées en détention.
J'ajoute que le garde des Sceaux
adressera dans les prochaines
heures une circulaire sur le
traitement des infractions
commises par des mineurs.
Pour que toutes les atteintes,
même de plus faible intensité,
soient sanctionnées, et aussi pour
mettre les parents face à leurs
responsabilités avec des amendes,
des stages de responsabilisation
parentale et en engageant leur
responsabilité pour soustraction à
l'autorité parentale.
Nous avons demandé au procureur de
prendre attache avec toutes les
victimes.
Notre volonté d'une réponse ferme,
d'une justice plus efficace et
rapide, et d'une réponse plus
adaptée pour les mineurs, c'est
tout l'engagement du gouvernement,
avec notamment la création d'un
code de justice pénale des
mineurs, et nous veillerons à sa
pleine mise en oeuvre.
C'est aussi le sens de la loi de
programmation du ministère de la
Justice que vous examinez
actuellement.
Je pense au recrutement de 10.000
nouveaux agents d'ici 2027 pour le
ministère de la Justice.
Je pense à la simplification de
notre procédure pénale.
Je pense aux meilleures
indemnisations des victimes.
Je pense à l'extension des travaux
d'intérêt général et je pense bien
sûr au programme de construction
de nouvelles places de prison
d'ici 2027, dont vous débattrez
dans les prochains jours.
Nous voulons une réponse pénale à
la hauteur.
Nous sommes mobilisés.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Aurore
Bergé, présidente du groupe
Renaissance.
- Aurore Bergé: Dimanche soir, un
homme de 24 ans est mort, mort en
service pour nous protéger des
émeutes et de ses conséquences.
Il s'appelait Dorian Damelincourt
et était sapeur-pompier.
Applaudissements
Désolée de vous dire que c'est
tout sauf hors sujet, mes chers
collègues.
800 policiers, pompiers ou
gendarmes ont été blessés.
A ceux qui crient au soi-disant
permis de tuer de nos forces de
l'ordre, ils méritent notre
soutien pour leur action.
Parce que, la vérité, c'est que le
décès brutal d'un jeune homme, ce
sera toujours un drame, mais il
reste sans rapport avec le
déferlement de violence.
Brûler nos bâtiments publics, des
écoles, des mairies, des
bibliothèques, tirer avec des
armes de guerre sur nos policiers,
attenter à la vie de nos élus et
leurs familles, piller des
commerces, il n'y a aucune justice
dans ces actions.
Quand on est un responsable
politique, on ne fait pas le tri
entre ce qui peut être brûlé et ce
qui ne peut pas l'être.
A ceux qui ont osé dire que la fin
justifie les moyens, à ceux qui
ont refusé d'appeler au calme,
vous serez jugés sévèrement par
les Français.
Nous devons avoir un discours de
vérité pour les parents, pour nos
jeunes qui doivent prendre
conscience de ces actes et de
leurs conséquences, un discours de
vérité face à ceux qui pensent que
nos banlieues ne sont peuplées que
de voyous armés.
Les Français qui vivent dans les
quartiers sont les premiers à
pleurer devant les écoles
détruites, les premiers à
respecter la République et à aimer
la France.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, madame la présidente.
- Aurore Bergé: Quelles sont les
mesures que votre gouvernement va
prendre?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Madame la
présidente Aurore Bergé, il y a
une semaine, jour pour jour, un
jeune homme de 17 ans a été tué
lors d'un contrôle routier, mais
bien vite, après ce drame,
l'émotion, légitime, a été
remplacée par une violence
inexcusable.
Les symboles de l'autorité ont été
spécifiquement visés.
Des pillages de magasins ont
ensuite éclaté.
Dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche,
la violence est montée d'un cran
avec l'attaque du domicile du
maire de L'Hay-les-Roses.
J'ai une pensée pour lui et sa
famille.
Notre priorité face à cette
violence est le retour de l'ordre
républicain.
Notre réponse s'est appuyée sur
quatre piliers: la mobilisation
des forces de l'ordre avec 45.000
policiers et gendarmes sur le
terrain, la fermeté de la réponse
pénale, la responsabilisation des
réseaux sociaux, et enfin, un
rappel nécessaire de la
responsabilité et de l'autorité
parentales, car les auteurs sont
jeunes, voire très jeunes.
Nous avons agi guidés par un
objectif: aucune impunité face aux
violences.
Grâce à cette intervention forte
de l'Etat, les violences ont
commencé à diminuer à partir de
samedi, avec une décrue très nette
dimanche soir et encore la nuit
passée.
Notre objectif est et reste de
garantir l'ordre républicain.
Nous sommes sur la bonne voie.
Mais nous restons extrêmement
vigilants.
C'est progressivement, avec la
plus grande prudence, que nous
adapterons notre dispositif de
sécurité.
Madame la présidente Bergé, avec
l'ensemble de la majorité, avec
l'ensemble des élus républicains,
nous sommes aux côtés des
policiers, des gendarmes et des
sapeurs-pompiers.
Nous saluons l'investissement des
magistrats.
Nous sommes avec les élus locaux
qui sont en première ligne.
Nous répondons présent pour les
habitants, les commerçants, les
artisans, les victimes de ces
violences.
Comme le président de la
République nous y a invités, nous
devons examiner aussi toutes les
causes de ces événements.
Comme je l'ai dit hier à
l'ensemble des présidents de
groupe, nous en tirerons toutes
les conséquences avec les groupes
de la majorité et tous les
parlementaires de l'arc
républicain.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Sébastien
Chenu pour le groupe Rassemblement
National.
- Sébastien Chenu: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse au garde des
Sceaux.
Il y a un an, vous nous disiez:
"Ce sera Emmanuel Macron ou le
chaos."
Aujourd'hui, c'est Emmanuel Macron
et le chaos.
Nous voulons adresser, nous,
députés du Rassemblement National,
notre reconnaissance, notre
gratitude aux forces de l'ordre
qui, partout dans le pays, ont
défendu les Français et leurs
biens.
Nous voulons penser à tous ces
Français, ces professionnels, qui,
dans les quartiers ou dans les
villes moyennes, ont été victimes.
Nous voulons vous dire aujourd'hui
que rien n'est le fruit du hasard.
Tout cela, en réalité, est le
fruit des politiques que vous
menez depuis des années, que vous
menez vous et vos prédécesseurs.
Mais il faut dire que c'était les
mêmes: même politique, même
logique, même absence de
résultats.
Votre responsabilité, en réalité,
est immense.
Les Français attendent de la
rapidité, ils attendent de la
cohérence et vous ne leur donnez
que l'inverse depuis des années.
Vos discours rimaient avec des
analyses sociologiques et des
rafistolages coûteux pour les
Français.
Aujourd'hui, vous constatez que
des villes moyennes sont
attaquées.
Ils brûlent ce qui fait symbole,
la France qu'ils détestent, celle
de la mémoire avec le mémorial
de la Shoah à Nanterre, en brûlant
des théâtres, la France de la
culture.
Oui, les Français refusent
désormais votre diktat et vos
intimidations morales.
A quel moment allez-vous entendre
nos propositions, comme celle de
revenir sur l'excuse de minorité
pour les mineurs ou les
allocations familiales pour les
familles de délinquants?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est au garde des Sceaux,
ministre de la Justice.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Monsieur le
président Chenu, merci d'abord de
ne pas tenter de me rappeler des
phrases que je n'ai jamais
prononcées.
Je vous mets au défi de me dire où
et quand je les ai prononcées.
En 2005, je n'avais absolument
aucune responsabilité, je n'étais
pas en politique, vous étiez déjà
à l'UMP.
Pour le reste, comment voulez-vous
que je réponde à une espèce de
symposium où vous évoquez à la
fois libertés individuelles et
déterminisme?
Un point précis sur lequel je peux
vous répondre: l'excuse de
minorité.
Si vous y revenez, je vous indique
tout de suite que le Conseil
constitutionnel vous censurera.
C'est tout à fait clair.
Parce que le Conseil
constitutionnel souhaite qu'on
fasse une différence entre les
mineurs et les majeurs, et je
pense que certains peuvent ici s'y
retrouver.
Pour le reste, le ministère de
l'Intérieur et de ministère de la
Justice ont fait front commun et
ils ont répondu de manière
républicaine aux troubles qui ont
secoué et bouleversé notre pays.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à monsieur Boris
Vallaud, président du groupe
socialiste.
- Boris Vallaud: Madame la
Première ministre, un adolescent
est mort lors d'un contrôle de
police, un adolescent qui n'aurait
pas dû mourir.
Nous disons l'immense tristesse
qui est la nôtre à la famille de
Nahel et à ses proches.
Depuis une semaine, la France a
connu des nuits de violence dans
des villes de toutes tailles, des
pillages et des destructions.
Ces actes sont intolérables.
Nous avons accompagné aux
premières heures des appels au
retour à la paix civile et au
respect de l'ordre public.
Nous pensons à toutes les
personnes, policiers et gendarmes,
pompiers et commerçants, qui ont
connu des agressions, la peur et
des destructions.
Nous devons nous tenir résolument
aux côtés de ceux-là.
Mais nous savons qu'il n'y a pas
d'ordre sans justice.
Voilà pourquoi on devra fournir
sans attendre des réponses
politiques.
Un pays dans lequel des milliers
de jeunes personnes, souvent
mineures, se lancent pendant des
jours et des nuits dans de telles
équipées est un pays qui va mal.
Notre responsabilité collective et
individuelle est d'en tirer toutes
les conséquences: ghettoïsation de
certains quartiers,
discriminations, mal-logement,
disparition des services publics,
mise en échec de nos institutions,
autant de difficultés profondes
dont ces débordements sont aussi
un symptôme.
Il faudra revenir sur le plan
Borloo, revenir sur l'éducation
populaire.
Nous devons aux Français, où
qu'ils vivent, la République
partout et pour tous.
Nous devons, avec sérénité et
sérieux, traiter de la question du
rapport entre la population et la
police, qui n'a cessé de se
détériorer.
Nous ne pouvons ignorer la
question de l'usage des armes, de
régulation de la loi que nous
réclamons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le président.
Madame la Première ministre, vous
avez la parole.
- Elisabeth Borne: Monsieur le
député Boris Vallaud, je tiens
tout d'abord à vous remercier, car
vous avez condamné sans ambiguïté
les violences qui ont touché de
nombreuses communes et appelé à la
paix civile, à la différence de
vos alliés insoumis.
Et, monsieur le président Vallaud,
j'entends vos interrogations sur
les racines de la crise et les
réponses que nous pouvons
apporter, notamment au travers de
la politique de la ville.
Cette réflexion de plus long
terme, elle aura lieu, mais je
peux vous dire que nous n'avons
pas cessé d'agir pour les
quartiers et pour la politique de
la ville depuis six ans.
Depuis 2017, nous avons augmenté
le budget de l'Agence nationale
pour la rénovation urbaine porté à
12 milliards d'euros.
Nous avons dédoublé les classes de
CP et de CE1 et déployé 100.000
emplois francs au bénéfice des
habitants des quartiers.
Nous devons mener une réflexion
approfondie sur les causes de
cette crise, avec tous les groupes
politiques de l'arc républicain.
Dans ces moments, notre
responsabilité, c'est l'écoute des
propositions des élus, notamment
des élus de terrain.
C'est aussi assumer collectivement
la complexité du sujet.
C'est notamment le sens de
l'échange que le président de la
République a en ce moment même
avec près de 300 maires dont les
communes ont été touchées par les
violences.
Comme nous en avons parlé hier,
nous sommes encore mobilisés et
concentrés sur le retour de
l'ordre républicain et la
réparation.
Nous sommes déterminés à agir pour
l'égal accès à nos services
publics et pour l'égalité des
chances sur tout notre territoire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, madame
la Première ministre.
La parole est à madame Cyrielle
Chatelain, présidente du groupe
écologiste.
- Cyrielle Chatelain: Madame la
Première ministre, de Montargis à
Lyon, d'Echirolles à Nanterre, des
villes aux campagnes, la révolte a
déchiré la France.
Voilà 18 ans que les politiques
échouent.
18 ans depuis la mort de Zyed et
Bouna.
Aujourd'hui, c'est Nahel qui est
tué.
18 années de disparition des
services publics.
18 années durant lesquelles le
contrat républicain a été bafoué.
La réalité, madame la Première
ministre, est qu'en France,
aujourd'hui, certaines vies valent
moins que d'autres, certains
territoires valent moins que
d'autres.
En France, l'égalité est un
concept théorique.
Brûler des écoles, piller des
magasins, agresser des élus, ce ne
sera jamais des actes de justice.
La violence ne pourra pas être la
solution.
C'est pourquoi, nous, écologistes,
membres de la NUPES, nous ne nous
résignons pas à un monde où
certains ont tout et d'autres ne
sont rien.
Il n'y a pas de fatalité.
Notre responsabilité est d'avoir
une réponse politique.
Annoncez la modification de la loi
de 2017, annoncez le retour de la
police de proximité et mettez en
place immédiatement des mesures de
lutte contre la discrimination et
contre le racisme.
Les politiques ne pourront jamais
réussir seuls.
Ecoutez les fonctionnaires, les
associations de terrain, les
maires et les parents, pas
seulement en période de crise mais
toute l'année.
Investissez dans la jeunesse.
Il nous faut une vraie politique
jeunesse.
Faites de l'école publique une
priorité.
Madame la Première ministre, quand
cesserez-vous d'être pétrifiée?
Quand prendrez-vous des mesures
pour recréer le lien que vous avez
laissé se désagréger?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, madame
la présidente.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Madame la
présidente Cyrielle Chatelain, il
y a une semaine, le drame de la
mort d'un jeune homme de 17 ans
lors d'un contrôle routier a
beaucoup choqué à travers notre
pays.
Face à ce drame, les réponses
viendront de la justice et pas de
la violence.
Vous l'avez dit vous-même.
Pourtant, depuis une semaine, des
violences ont éclaté dans
certaines communes.
Ces violences, vous les avez
condamnées.
Je veux saluer cette attitude
républicaine qui tranche avec
celle de certains de vos alliés.
Madame la présidente, ces
violences n'ont rien à voir avec
une révolte des banlieues.
J'ai été à Nanterre, à
Garges-lès-Gonesse, et revenait
sans cesse l'incompréhension et la
colère vis-à-vis de ces auteurs de
violences qui mettent à mal des
politiques menées depuis des
années, tous les efforts menés
dans la politique de la ville,
notamment dans le précédent
quinquennat, pour rénover ces
quartiers, renforcer l'accès aux
services publics.
Vis-à-vis de la jeunesse, madame
la présidente, nous avons agi tout
au long du précédent quinquennat
avec le développement de
l'apprentissage, avec les emplois
francs, avec aujourd'hui la
réforme du lycée professionnel.
Madame la présidente Chatelain,
ces violences sont inexcusables,
elles ne représentent pas la
jeunesse de notre pays.
Nous accompagnons tous les
Français, tous les jeunes dans
tous les territoires de la
République.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, madame
la Première ministre.
La parole est à monsieur Jean-Paul
Mattei, président du groupe
démocrate.
- Jean-Paul Mattei: Mardi dernier,
un drame s'est produit avec la
mort du jeune Nahel.
La justice doit suivre son cours,
dans le respect des principes de
l'état de droit.
Depuis, des quartiers entiers se
sont enflammés: plus de 5000
véhicules enflammés, 1000
bâtiments brûlés, dégradés ou
pillés.
Ces exactions doivent être
condamnées parce qu'elles
détruisent les biens communs.
L'Etat a répondu rapidement et
vigoureusement, tant par le nombre
des forces de l'ordre mobilisées
que par les actions de la justice
très rapidement mises en oeuvre.
Je veux saluer ici le courage et
le sang-froid des policiers et des
gendarmes, et celui des pompiers,
bien sûr.
Mais je veux aussi saluer les
maires, serviteurs de la
République, qui ont été au front
jour et nuit depuis mardi.
Ils sont au centre de toute
action.
Ils sont victimes, souvent,
d'agression, et même, désormais,
ce sont leurs familles qui sont en
première ligne.
C'est inacceptable.
Sans eux, notre République n'est
rien ou peu de choses.
Ils ont à leurs côtés tous les
bénévoles, leurs conseils
municipaux, le corps enseignant et
le monde associatif.
Au nom de mon groupe, je veux
rendre hommage aux maires et vous
demander d'apporter tout le
soutien dont le gouvernement est
capable.
Il faut leur donner les moyens de
reconstruire les médiathèques, les
écoles, les antennes de police,
tous ces lieux qui font le coeur
de notre territoire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Monsieur le
président Jean-Paul Mattei, les
épisodes de violence de ces
derniers jours connaissent
aujourd'hui une décrue importante,
mais je n'oublie pas les dégâts
causés.
Ce sont des mairies, des écoles,
des commissariats, des brigades de
gendarmerie, des postes de police
municipale et des bâtiments
publics vandalisés et parfois
incendiés.
Ce sont des commerces, des bureaux
de tabac saccagés et pillés.
Ce sont des voitures brûlées.
C'est inacceptable, et nous sommes
aux côtés de toutes les victimes
de violences, de dégradation ou de
pillage.
Nous veillerons à ce que les
collectivités territoriales soient
accompagnées.
Les procédures seront allégées et
les délais réduits au maximum, et
l'Etat viendra en soutien lorsque
c'est nécessaire.
C'est précisément, en ce moment
même, ce que fait le président de
la République, qui échange avec
ces maires, pour qu'ils puissent
au plus vite remettre en service
leurs équipements publics.
Nous serons aux côtés des
habitants et des commerçants, des
artisans, et les commerçants
touchés pourront bénéficier d'un
report de charges fiscales et
sociales.
Les plus touchés pourront même
bénéficier d'une annulation de ces
charges.
Bien sûr, nous demandons la
mobilisation des assureurs, dont
c'est d'abord la responsabilité.
Le ministre de l'Economie Bruno Le
Maire les a rencontrés samedi
dernier et hier encore.
Les assureurs se sont engagés à
tout faire pour faciliter la vie
des victimes de violences.
Nous voulons reconstruire vite, et
nous serons aux côtés des élus,
des commerçants, des artisans et
de toutes les victimes de
violence.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, madame
la Première ministre.
La parole est à Stéphane Peu.
- Stéphane Peu: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à la
Première ministre.
Dans son immense majorité, le pays
a dit son indignation devant la
mort du jeune Nahel.
Depuis mercredi, je ne cesse de
croiser des gens en colère devant
les violences et les destructions
inacceptables.
L'heure doit être à l'apaisement,
mais les appels à l'unité et à la
fermeté ne suffiront pas, aussi
indispensables soient-ils.
Il ne faudra pas regarder ailleurs
une fois le calme revenu.
Je veux d'abord rétablir une
vérité: non, il n'y a pas de
territoires perdus de la
République, il n'y a que des
territoires que la République
abandonne.
Ainsi, depuis 2005, hormis la
rénovation urbaine, tout s'est
dégradé, notamment l'école, qui
devrait être la prunelle de nos
yeux et qui est le service public
le plus maltraité.
L'école est maltraitée, car les
moyens alloués par le biais de la
République ne compensent jamais
l'affaiblissement des politiques
de droit commun.
Maltraitée car, dans le
secondaire, il faudrait 45.000
personnes de plus pour retrouver
le taux d'encadrement de 2006.
Or, en 6 ans, vous avez supprimé
8900 emplois.
Maltraitée quand, dans l'académie
de Créteil, on admet au concours
de professeurs avec une note de
4/20 alors que le seuil est de
14/20 dans le reste de la France.
En plus, on s'apprête à pourvoir
les postes par le recrutement sur
Leboncoin ou par des jobs dating.
Ce n'est pas ça, l'école de la
République.
Nous croyons encore aux mots de
Victor Hugo selon lesquels "Quand
on ouvre une école, on ferme une
prison".
Nous croyons que l'école est une
partie de notre République.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
Le temps est largement dépassé.
La parole est à monsieur Pap
Ndiaye, ministre de l'Education
nationale et de la Jeunesse.
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le député Stéphane Peu,
non, la République n'abandonne
aucun territoire.
L'Education nationale n'abandonne
Elle n'abandonne pas les filles et
les fils de la République.
Dans le département que vous
citez, la Seine-Saint-Denis, les
moyens d'enseignement, alors même
que la population scolaire va
baisser notablement l'année
prochaine, les moyens
d'enseignement restent au même
niveau.
Monsieur le député, c'est pour
cela que nous augmentons...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur Peu!
- Pap Ndiaye: Un peu de respect
pour les enseignants, y compris
pour les enseignants contractuels.
Laissez-moi m'exprimer.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Un peu de
calme, s'il vous plaît!
Un peu de calme.
Monsieur le ministre, vous avez la
parole.
- Pap Ndiaye: Ce que nous faisons
en Seine-Saint-Denis
particulièrement, cela a été,
monsieur le député, le
dédoublement des classes de CP, de
CE1 et de grande section.
Ca a été l'école apprenante, les
cités éducatives créées ces
dernières années.
Ce sont des moyens d'enseignement
supplémentaires.
Ce sera bientôt l'ouverture de
toutes petites sections.
C'est aussi les horaires en
scolaire et en périscolaire
étendus de 8h le matin jusqu'à
18h.
C'est également, à la rentrée
2024, les bourses scolaires qui
seront versées automatiquement
sans que les personnes n'aient à
les réclamer.
C'est enfin un plan pour les 40
collèges les plus en difficulté
sur les 130.
Ca ne vous intéresse pas, ma
réponse?
Je vous la donne quand même, parce
que je m'intéresse à la
Seine-Saint-Denis et je n'en fais
pas un argument de politique
politicienne!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Bertrand
Pancher, président du groupe LIOT.
- Bertrand Pancher: Avec
l'ensemble des députés du groupe
LIOT, je voulais apporter mon
soutien aux commerçants, aux
forces de sécurité et aux
habitants touchés par les
violences de notre pays.
Et évidemment, à la famille du
jeune Nahel.
Nous condamnons toutes ces
violences sans réserve.
Rien ne peut justifier
destructions et pillages.
Il est une chose que j'ai
cependant apprise de mes mandats
locaux: l'action publique appelle
l'humilité.
J'ai entendu des analyses de
pseudo-experts, responsables
politiques alimentant les discours
de haine.
Il n'y a pas de solution miracle.
Il y a des appels au calme et une
politique de cohésion sociale.
On ne peut pas traiter séparément
les questions de sécurité des
réponses pénales, des
discriminations, d'accès à
l'emploi ou d'éducation.
Tout est lié.
Il faut prendre tous ces maux à la
racine pour proposer des solutions
adaptées à nos territoires.
J'ai relu le rapport Borloo.
Il y avait un constat:
l'immobilisme allait créer une
nouvelle crise.
Nous y sommes.
Certes, des choses ont été faites,
mais si peu.
Nous avons la crainte que des
solutions partielles soient mises
en place et que l'on passe à autre
chose.
Nous craignons qu'une autre crise
survienne.
Il faut des solutions globales
construites avec les élus locaux,
l'Education nationale.
Nous avons appelé cela un Conseil
des sages.
Il convient de reprendre le
rapport Borloo, de l'actualiser.
Les valeurs de notre République ne
peuvent progresser que si la
promesse d'égalité est possible.
Ma question est simple: quand
allons-nous construire enfin un
destin commun redonnant espoir à
nos concitoyens?
Le président Macron y est-il prêt
en y associant toutes les forces
vives de notre pays?
Est-il prêt à reconstruire un
monde plus humain, plus juste,
plus fraternel?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci.
Monsieur le président Bertrand
Pancher, permettez-moi d'abord de
vous remercier pour votre attitude
profondément républicaine et sans
ambiguïté face aux violences
inacceptables qui ont eu lieu ces
derniers jours.
Dans ces moments, il est essentiel
que tous les élus attachés aux
valeurs de la République
continuent...
Oui, vous avez un problème quand
je parle des élus attachés à la
République, mesdames et messieurs
les députés?
Il est donc essentiel que tous les
élus attachés aux valeurs de la
République continuent à parler
d'une seule voix, dans un esprit
républicain, pour dénoncer les
violences, les atteintes
inqualifiables aux élus et pour
soutenir nos policiers, nos
gendarmes et nos sapeurs-pompiers.
Comme vous, je sais que le retour
au calme ne résoudra pas tout,
mais il est le préalable
indispensable à toute action de
long terme.
Viendra ensuite le temps des
débats de fond.
Je veux vous dire que pendant 6
ans, nous n'avons pas cessé d'agir
pour la politique de la ville.
Vous mentionnez le rapport de
Jean-Louis Borloo, vous avez eu
raison de le faire, et nous avons
repris un grand nombre de ses
propositions.
Nous avons augmenté
considérablement les budgets de
l'ANRU.
Nous avons fait de l'éducation et
de la jeunesse des piliers de la
politique de la ville.
Je pense notamment aux cités
éducatives que nous avons créé
pour lutter contre les inégalités.
Je pense au dédoublement des
classes de CP et de CE1 que nous
étendons aux grandes sections.
Ce n'est pas tout.
Nous avons agi pour l'emploi, et
si le taux de chômage est encore
trop élevé dans les quartiers, il
a baissé de 5 points depuis 2017.
Nous sommes déterminés à
travailler et à agir pour nos
quartiers, pour tous nos
territoires et nous le ferons pour
tous les élus engagés pour l'unité
de notre pays.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Laurent
Marcangeli, président du groupe
Horizons.
- Laurent Marcangeli: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre, notre
pays a vécu ces derniers jours des
heures effroyables.
Rien ne peut justifier de
s'attaquer à des écoles, à des
bibliothèques, à des locaux
d'associations qui oeuvrent pour
le bien commun.
Nos concitoyens voient leur
voiture être brûlée, des
commerçants voient leur magasin
être pillé et parfois même de
simples passants qui se trouvent
au mauvais endroit au mauvais
moment sont attaqués sauvagement.
Je tiens d'ores et déjà à saluer,
au nom du groupe Horizons et
apparentés, le travail
exceptionnel réalisé par nos
forces de secours et de sécurité.
Elles ont souvent été mobilisées
sur des territoires qui n'étaient
pas les leurs dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles que nous
connaissons tous.
Nous souhaitons aussi rendre
hommage à l'engagement sans faille
dont font preuve nos élus de
terrain qui refusent de reculer
face aux menaces et aux
agressions.
Mes chers collègues, il n'y a
aucune revendication sociale à
trouver dans ces agissements
inacceptables, aucune colère
légitime, aucune excuse, mais
seulement des actes de sécession
d'une minorité qui rejette toute
forme d'autorité.
Ces rejets de l'ordre républicain
se font au détriment de dizaines
de millions de Français qui n'ont
qu'une seule envie, une seule
demande: celle d'un cadre de vie
paisible pour eux et pour leur
famille.
Comment, par ailleurs, ne pas être
interloqué par le jeune âge des
individus interpellés?
Que font ces mineurs seuls,
parfois toute la nuit, dans la
rue?
Où sont leurs parents, titulaires
de l'autorité parentale et chargés
de veiller à leur éducation et à
leur sécurité?
Qui surveille l'attitude et
l'activité de ces jeunes sur les
réseaux sociaux et sur Internet?
Madame la Première ministre, votre
capacité à faire nation est
gravement menacée par ces
événements récents.
Comment comptez-vous réaffirmer
l'autorité de l'Etat et la
primauté du pacte républicain,
face à des individus qui semblent
prêts à tout pour faire régner le
chaos?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le président Laurent
Marcangeli, vous avez raison de le
dire, les violences de ces
derniers jours sont inacceptables,
et je veux à nouveau rendre
hommage à nos policiers, nos
gendarmes, nos sapeurs-pompiers,
dont le courage est exceptionnel
face aux violences de ces derniers
jours.
Notre priorité, c'est de garantir
le retour au calme et d'assurer la
sécurité de tous les Français.
Comme l'a dit le président de la
République, nous devons aussi
engager une réflexion sur les
causes profondes de cette
situation et la représentation
nationale y prendra naturellement
toute sa part.
Nous examinerons tous les sujets
sans exception, sans tabou, ni
faux-semblants.
Nous devons notamment assurer le
respect de l'autorité en général
et de l'exercice de l'autorité
parentale.
Nous devons mieux réguler les
réseaux sociaux et vous aurez
l'occasion d'examiner
prochainement un texte visant à
mieux sécuriser et réguler
l'espace numérique.
Comme l'a dit le président de la
République, nous devons renforcer
nos réponses en sanctionnant les
jeunes dès le premier écart.
Avec vous, monsieur le président
Marcangeli, avec l'ensemble des
députés de la majorité, avec
toutes celles et ceux qui veulent
construire des solutions, nous
refusons les caricatures et les
idées toutes faites.
Notre objectif, c'est l'efficacité
dans les réponses, ce sont les
solutions pour les habitants des
quartiers, pour les habitants de
tous nos territoires et pour notre
jeunesse.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Michaël
Taverne pour le Rassemblement
National.
- Michaël Taverne: Merci.
Des dizaines d'années d'errements,
d'idéologie, voire de soumission.
Voilà les causes de la situation
dramatique qui touche notre pays.
Tous ceux qui se sont succédé au
pouvoir portent une part de
responsabilité dans ce chaos.
Souvenez-vous, Emmanuel Macron
assurait que ce serait lui ou le
chaos.
C'est pourtant bien la politique
qui a accouché du chaos que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui.
Ma question portera sur l'aspect
sécuritaire de ce chaos et
s'adresse au ministre de
l'Intérieur.
L'événement tragique de Nanterre
et les émeutes qui en ont découlé
dans tout le pays ont démontré une
nouvelle fois aux yeux de millions
de Français que tout était
prétexte à détruire, à incendier
et à piller.
Le chaos sécuritaire qui a touché
l'ensemble de notre pays s'inscrit
bien sûr dans le chaos migratoire
que nous subissons et contre
lequel vous restez les bras
ballants.
Malgré nos alertes depuis des
années, le gouvernement continue
la politique de l'autruche et
cette réalité vous revient en
pleine figure.
Vous-même, monsieur le ministre,
vous paraissez dépassé et
déconnecté en affirmant que dans
la nuit de vendredi à samedi,
l'intensité était moindre, alors
que c'était la pire.
Quel visionnaire!
Je ne parle pas du piétinement au
plus haut sommet de l'Etat de la
présomption d'innocence de celui
qui servait la République sous
l'uniforme policier!
Face à ces prédateurs barbares qui
défient l'autorité de l'Etat, à
quand ce sursaut sécuritaire pour
soutenir les forces de l'ordre?
A quand ce sursaut politique pour
expulser les délinquants
étrangers?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Madame la
présidente, monsieur le député,
suite aux événements dramatiques
de Nanterre où, je crois, j'ai pu
m'exprimer pour dire en effet que
la justice devait être faite en
respectant la présomption
d'innocence qui est due à tous les
citoyens, y compris aux forces de
l'ordre, je veux ici dire d'abord
mon soutien aux 808 policiers,
gendarmes et sapeurs-pompiers
blessés, et évidemment à ce
caporal-chef de la brigade des
sapeurs-pompiers de Paris.
Je crois que dans un moment aussi
terrible pour notre pays, il ne
faudrait pas...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: S'il vous
plaît!
Vous n'avez pas la parole!
Laissez le ministre répondre.
- Gérald Darmanin: Il faut se
rappeler que la République est un
équilibre.
Oui, l'ordre et la fermeté.
Oui, l'ordre juste, et pas juste
l'ordre.
Oui, il faut écouter les policiers
et gendarmes qui travaillent
difficilement dans tous les
quartiers de la République.
Je suis, je crois, le premier à
les soutenir.
Oui, monsieur le député, il faut
aussi ne pas confondre les débats.
Moins de 10% des interpellés
étaient étrangers.
90% étaient français.
40 personnes seulement étaient
éligibles à un centre de rétention
administrative.
La question d'aujourd'hui, c'est
les jeunes délinquants, pas les
étrangers.
Nous sommes nombreux ici à être
issus des quartiers et de
l'immigration et à aimer notre
pays!
Nous ne voulons ni de la haine des
policiers, ni de la haine des
étrangers!
Nous voulons l'amour de la
République!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
Vous pouvez répondre.
- Michaël Taverne: Le mépris qui
vous caractérise révèle bien au
grand jour votre incompétence!
La seule qui répondra aux
problèmes de sécurité, c'est
Marine Le Pen!
La seule qui mettra en place une
politique, c'est Marine Le Pen!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Alexandre Vincendet
pour le groupe Les Républicains.
- Alexandre Vincendet: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
En tant que député de la 7e
circonscription du Rhône, j'ai été
comme beaucoup d'autres dans cet
hémicycle au coeur du chaos de ces
derniers jours.
Madame la Première ministre, ma
question est double.
Nos forces de sécurité, police
nationale, gendarmerie, police
municipale et pompiers, ont été
héroïques.
La République doit leur être
reconnaissante.
Il faut rappeler la responsabilité
des parents.
La République, c'est des droits et
des devoirs, y compris pour les
parents.
Il est urgent d'en tirer toutes
les conséquences.
Alors que les voyous font l'objet
de poursuites, qu'entendez-vous
faire à l'encontre des émeutiers
par procuration, ceux qui ont
refusé d'appeler au calme, ceux
qui, à force de tout excuser en
permanence, ont mis de l'huile sur
le feu, comme monsieur Mélenchon
qui, en 2012, fustigeait les
hordes de casseurs, les traitant
de crétins, de bouffons et de
larbins de la société capitaliste?
Aujourd'hui, il les incite à la
violence en sélectionnant les
cibles visées, les appelle à la
sédition par des responsables
politiques
et c'est intolérable.
La deuxième partie de ma question
concerne la politique de la ville.
Elu maire en 2014, nous avons
engagé un plan de rénovation
urbaine sans précédent.
L'argent est là, le problème,
c'est que les procédures sont trop
longues.
Le temps d'action est trop long.
Les décisions prises en 2014, les
premiers effets ne se font sentir
que 10 à 20 ans après.
C'est tellement long et complexe
que ça on devient illisible pour
nos concitoyens qui, pour
l'immense majorité, font tout pour
vivre dans la dignité et le
respect de la République.
Que comptez-vous faire pour aider
les maires à faire plus vite, plus
fort et plus efficacement?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu, ministre de la
Transition écologique et de la
Cohésion des territoires.
- Christophe Béchu: Madame la
présidente, monsieur le député
Alexandre Vincendet.
Ce matin, à l'Elysée, plus de 200
maires de toutes sensibilités
politiques, de toutes tailles de
communes étaient autour du
président de la République pour
partager leur désarroi, leurs
constats.
J'entends aussi certains qui
lancent des phrases dans cet
hémicycle.
Le premier soutien que nous devons
leur apporter, c'est d'évoquer ce
sujet avec un minimum de respect.
On ne peut pas à la fois saluer
les fonctionnaires, les élus et
les forces de l'ordre, et quand on
les évoque et que l'on pose une
question pour la manière de les
accompagner, utiliser des
raccourcis ou faire en sorte de
pousser sa propre idéologie sans
prendre le temps d'entendre ce
qu'ils ont à dire sur cette
réalité.
Ces maires, ils disent qu'il y a
des lourdeurs administratives,
qu'il faut faire en sorte de ne
pas jeter la politique de la ville
avec l'eau du bain et qu'il y a
des dizaines de milliards d'euros
qui ont été investis, qui ont
permis dans certains endroits de
permettre des réussites.
Dans le même temps, ce n'est pas
parce qu'il y a ces images qui
sont terribles qu'il faut que l'on
occulte l'histoire et les parcours
qui ont pu être réussis.
Quand une famille s'en sort, qui
la remplace?
Une famille qui est à nouveau
parmi les plus fragiles.
Etre capable de regarder cette
réalité en face, c'est mesurer
l'ampleur du combat pour la
mixité.
On gagnera si on est tous
ensemble.
Je veux vous rejoindre sur les
silences indécents de l'extrême
gauche, de Mélenchon, parce que ce
sont ces silences qui ont
contribué à mettre le feu aux
poudres.
Dans ces quartiers, les habitants
méritent plus que vous les
traitiez comme des émeutiers en
puissance.
Votre mépris de classe pour les
habitants des quartiers
populaires, il éclate dans la
façon dont vous les
instrumentalisez.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Sacha
Houlié du groupe Renaissance.
- Sacha Houlié: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur Eric
Dupond-Moretti.
Monsieur le garde des Sceaux, ces
derniers jours, partout en France,
d'importantes émeutes ont eu lieu
après la mort de Nahel.
Je veux apporter mon soutien à sa
famille.
La justice a été saisie.
Ce drame ne peut servir au
prétexte de ce que nous avons
constaté.
Je salue l'attitude responsable de
la majorité, des élus qui ont
appelé au calme, à l'exception de
La France Insoumise.
Ce que nos concitoyens attendent
aujourd'hui, c'est de la justesse
dans le prononcé de la justice.
En moins d'une semaine, les forces
de l'ordre ont procédé à plus de
3000 interpellations.
Compte tenu de la gravité des
faits, pouvez-vous nous faire
connaître les instructions que
vous avez données au procureur
afin qu'il soit intraitable dans
ses réquisitions?
Est-ce que ces demandes ont été
suivies par les magistrats?
Pouvons-nous connaître la nature
des peines prononcées contre les
émeutiers?
Pouvez-vous nous assurer que les
peines seront bien appliquées,
comme le sont 95% des peines
prononcées?
Monsieur le garde des Sceaux, ces
émeutiers sont jeunes, souvent
mineurs.
Parfois, ils ont 17 ans.
D'autres ont 14 ans, voire 12 ans.
Vous avez posé la question de
l'autorité parentale, vous avez eu
raison.
La médiation parentale dans les
quartiers populaires méritera
d'être renforcée.
Dans l'attente, quelles
instructions avez-vous données
pour s'assurer que les parents ne
laissent pas traîner leurs fils?
Comme le président de la
République, vous avez pointé la
responsabilité des réseaux
sociaux.
Derrière les écrans, trop de
jeunes ou de moins jeunes se
pensent surhumains, intouchables.
Ils disent n'importe quoi et
attisent la colère.
Comment les identifier, les
déférer et supprimer les
insupportables contenus qu'ils
éditent?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Eric Dupond-Moretti.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Merci.
Monsieur le président Houlié,
d'abord, je partage ce que vous
dites, l'émotion que suscite la
mort de ce jeune homme, mais en
rien elle ne peut justifier les
saccages et les pillages, les
exactions auxquelles nous avons
assisté.
Oui, dès vendredi, j'ai pris une
circulaire de politique générale à
l'intention des procureurs
généraux.
Je leur ai demandé de la fermeté
et de la réactivité.
L'encre de la circulaire était à
peine sèche que déjà, les
procureurs la mettaient en oeuvre.
Je veux ici de façon solennelle
leur rendre hommage.
Ils ont été au rendez-vous.
Ils ont été au rendez-vous de la
justice.
Je veux rendre hommage également
aux magistrats du siège, aux
greffiers, qui, pendant des heures
et des heures, ont répondu à ces
exactions insupportables.
Voilà ce que nous avons fait.
D'abord, j'ai demandé aux
procureurs qu'ils requièrent
auprès des réseaux sociaux pour
que l'on trouve les noms et les
adresses des utilisateurs.
Il n'y a pas un gamin qui doit
encore penser aujourd'hui qu'il
peut échapper à sa responsabilité.
Ensuite, la responsabilité des
parents.
Il y a des parents, voyez-vous,
qui sont en capacité d'exercer
l'autorité parentale et qui ne
l'exercent pas.
Non, être à 12 ans dans la rue, ce
n'est pas normal.
Je viens de mettre en place, dans
une autre circulaire, un certain
nombre de directives pour que l'on
rappelle à l'ensemble des parents
les obligations qui sont les
leurs.
Enfin, naturellement, la justice a
été au rendez-vous de la fermeté
que j'appelais de mes voeux.
350 incarcérations ont été
prononcées.
Voilà ce que je voulais dire.
Nous avons besoin de la justice...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Antoine
Léaument pour le groupe La France
Insoumise.
- Antoine Léaument: Merci.
Monsieur Darmanin, ce vendredi,
les syndicats factieux Alliance et
UNSA police ont menacé les
pouvoirs législatifs et
judiciaires.
Un nouveau cap est franchi.
Quand rappellerez-vous à Alliance
que la police n'est pas là pour
donner des ordres, mais pour
servir et obéir?
La vérité, c'est que vous êtes
paralysé par la peur.
Vous avez peur de finir comme
monsieur Christophe Castaner pour
avoir dénoncé les clés
d'étranglement.
Vous avez peur de fermer la
cagnotte lancée par un raciste.
Vous avez peur que la police se
retourne contre vous.
Voilà ce qui arrive quand on fait
reposer l'autorité de l'Etat sur
la répression et non sur
l'adhésion.
Cette peur paralyse votre action.
Au nom des jeunes morts dans ma
circonscription âgés de 13 à 17,
je veux vous parler de cette
merveille.
"Ferme ta gueule!
Tu veux qu'on t'encule ou quoi?"
Ce sont les propos de la police.
Cela vous choque?
Tant mieux.
Le gouvernement dit que la police
doit se comporter de manière
exemplaire.
Pensez-vous que ces insultes
inspirent respect et
considération?
Pensez-vous qu'ils emploient autre
chose qu'un vocabulaire raciste?
Il n'existe pas en République
d'ennemis de l'intérieur.
Le racisme est un délit.
C'est le poison de la République.
Quand allez-vous limoger et punir
les policiers racistes qui
salissent l'uniforme de leurs
collègues républicains?
On est tous Français, on doit
avoir les mêmes droits!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin, ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer.
Brouhaha
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Un peu de
silence.
- Gérald Darmanin: Monsieur le
député, il ne faut pas tout
confondre.
Un policier a été mis en examen.
Tous les policiers n'ont pas été
mis en examen.
Des délinquants de certains
quartiers ont mis à sac des
villes.
Tous les habitants des quartiers
n'ont pas mis à sac les villes.
Des syndicats de police émettent
des communiqués.
Non, monsieur le député, le
ministre de l'Intérieur ne corrige
aucun communiqué d'aucun syndicat.
Une cagnotte a été ouverte, il
faut la fermer.
Non, monsieur le député, il
appartient à la justice de notre
pays de pouvoir fermer cette
cagnotte.
Monsieur le député, faites mentir
la phrase de Jacques Brel.
Soyez au rendez-vous de la
République.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
Marie-Noëlle Battistel pour le
groupe socialiste.
Vous venez de poser une question.
Daignez écouter la question
suivante.
- Marie-Noëlle Battistel: A
l'hôpital, à la campagne ou en
ville, des constats de carence
sont tirés.
J'attire votre attention sur
l'accès aux soins de gynécologie
médicale qui est sinistrée dans
notre pays et même impossible dans
13 départements, comme le relève
un récent rapport du Sénat.
Le sujet touche prioritairement
les femmes et nous touche toutes
et tous.
Entre 2000 et 2020, la France a
connu une baisse de plus de 50% de
son effectif de gynécologues
médicaux.
Nous faisons le constat de la
nécessité d'aller plus loin, plus
vite, et donc augmenter le nombre
d'internes en cette spécialité.
Ce déficit s'aggravera si on ne
fait rien.
On constate des conséquences
néfastes pour de nombreuses
femmes.
Notre amendement transpartisan de
régulation aurait pu être un début
de réponse au problème des déserts
médicaux dans toutes les
disciplines.
Monsieur le ministre, permettre
une prise en charge gynécologique
générale des femmes aide à leur
émancipation.
Comment comptez-vous reconstituer
durablement les effectifs de cette
profession, alors qu'à l'horizon
2030, nous pourrions encore perdre
20% de nos spécialistes?
Envisagez-vous d'accroître les
compétences des sages-femmes en
matière de prescription?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est au ministre de la
Santé.
- François Braun: Madame la
députée, le manque de
professionnels de santé est un
véritable défi pour notre système
de santé.
Ce manque de professionnels de
santé, malheureusement, quelles
que soient les spécialités, est le
résultat d'une gestion aveugle des
effectifs médicaux et
paramédicaux.
Nous avons supprimé le numerus
clausus.
Nous avons maintenant plus de 15%
d'étudiants qui sont acceptés en
deuxième année de médecine.
Nous avons renforcé les formations
infirmières en lien avec les
régions.
Nous avons également un enjeu
majeur sur ces infirmières,
l'abandon des études pour 10%
d'entre elles.
Nous avons lancé une réforme
complète du métier et de la
formation d'infirmière pour les
maintenir dans les territoires et
dans les formations.
En ce qui concerne les réponses
que nous pourrons apporter,
au-delà de ces chiffres, nous
devons redonner du temps médical
aux professionnels.
Nous devons leur supprimer toutes
les tâches inutiles, pour
lesquelles ils n'ont pas de
plus-value.
Nous avons favorisé l'exercice
pluriprofessionnel pour coordonner
la gynécologie médicale.
L'élargissement des compétences
des sages-femmes permet d'apporter
une réponse au niveau des
territoires où nous manquons de
gynécologues.
Au-delà de ce partage de
connaissances, l'exercice
coordonné par des assistants
médicaux permet d'augmenter de 10%
le potentiel de patients pris en
charge par un médecin sans
travailler plus.
Il y a des réponses sur deux
niveaux: augmenter le nombre de
professionnels dans toutes les
spécialités, la gynécologie en
profitera, et redonner plus de
temps aux professionnels pour
prendre en charge plus de
patients.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Prisca
Thevenot.
- Prisca Thevenot: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer.
"Je n'en veux pas à la police mais
seulement à une personne, celle
qui a ôté la vie à mon fils."
Ce sont les mots prononcés par la
maman de Nahel.
Ces mots ont trouvé une réponse
auprès de notre justice.
Oui, le policier, l'homme en
question, a été effectivement mis
en examen pour homicide volontaire
et placé sous détention
provisoire.
Il devra répondre de ses actes, et
c'est d'ailleurs ce que le
président de la République a
rappelé, ainsi que la Première
ministre, le garde des Sceaux et
vous, monsieur le ministre.
Cela vous déplaît, mais nous
sommes dans un état de droit, et
c'est ainsi que nous fonctionnons
dans un état de droit.
Cet état de droit, depuis un an,
souffre des amalgames et des
exagérations mensongères d'une
partie des bancs de cet hémicycle
qui préfère se rouler en boule
dans des polémiques plutôt que de
faire de la politique.
Eh oui, je parle de vous, mesdames
et messieurs de La France
Insoumise.
Ne vous en déplaise, nous nous
dresserons pour que notre
République continue d'exister et
défendre ces valeurs.
Nous ne le faisons pas seuls.
Nous le faisons grâce à l'action
résolue de ces femmes et de ces
hommes qui, sur le terrain,
continuent de nous protéger et
d'assurer notre sécurité.
Je parle bien évidemment de nos
forces de l'ordre.
Monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer, ma
question est simple: comment, face
à ce chaos voulu par certains,
arrivez-vous encore à trouver les
mots pour rassurer ces hommes et
ces femmes pour qu'ils ne
démissionnent pas, qu'ils ne
désespèrent pas?
Car oui, une partie de la
représentation nationale préfère
aujourd'hui les pointer du doigt
au risque de les menacer.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est au ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer.
- Gérald Darmanin: Madame la
députée, les 250.000 policiers et
gendarmes auxquels on pourrait
rajouter les douaniers et les
policiers municipaux font un
travail extrêmement difficile et
très exigeant, dangereux.
Ils sont les filles et les fils du
peuple, qui passent des concours,
subissent une formation, sont
particulièrement regardés par leur
hiérarchie, comme ayant des
responsabilités, et sont donc à ce
titre, et c'est normal, dans un
souci de déontologie, d'exigence,
et, lorsqu'ils ne respectent pas
ces exigences de probité et de
déontologie, ils sont sanctionnés.
Ils sont parmi les agents publics
les plus contrôlés.
Ce n'est pas parce qu'il y a du
tumulte, parce qu'il y a du
brouhaha et parce qu'il y a de la
politique politicienne que l'on
doit distinguer les morts.
Le drame de Nanterre, toute la
nation le pleure.
Je pense aussi à Mélanie, cette
gendarme du Lot-et-Garonne, tuée
par un refus d'obtempérer à 26
ans.
Je pense aussi à ce jeune policier
de la circonscription de Lille qui
laisse une orpheline de 7 ans
parce qu'un chauffeur ne s'est pas
arrêté.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
on ne doit pas se rejeter les
morts d'un camp à un autre.
On doit respecter les règles de la
République pour tous les citoyens,
qu'ils soient ou non policiers.
Il n'y a pas deux bandes rivales,
les policiers et les voyous, il
n'y a que la République qui doit
parler à tous les citoyens sans
distinction de race, de religion
et de croyance.
Et il doit y avoir unanimité
politique pour combattre ceux qui
mettent le feu sur les écoles et
qui tirent à bout portant sur les
forces de l'ordre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à monsieur Benjamin
Lucas.
- Benjamin Lucas: Malik Oussekine,
Bouna Traoré, Adama Traoré,
Aboubacar Fofana, Steve Maia
Caniço, Cédric Chouviat, Nahel...
Ces noms, ce sont des vies
arrachées, des familles
endeuillées, des villes meurtries
par une mémoire traumatique que le
temps n'efface jamais.
Quand vous niez la réalité des
contrôles au faciès, vous refusez
de porter un regard lucide que
devrait avoir une grande
démocratie comme la nôtre sur le
réel.
Pour que les mêmes causes ne
produisent pas les mêmes effets,
allez-vous enfin reconnaître la
réalité, madame la Première
ministre, et mettre autour de la
table les citoyens, les élus
locaux, les éducateurs, les
fonctionnaires de police, et
étudier enfin les propositions
pour établir un lien de confiance
entre toute la population et la
police républicaine?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin, ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer.
- Gérald Darmanin: Monsieur le
député, qu'il faille améliorer
sans cesse le travail des agents
publics et des forces de l'ordre,
c'est une évidence.
C'est cette majorité qui a
augmenté de quatre mois la
formation des gardiens de la paix.
Vous ne l'avez pas voté.
Il fallait augmenter la formation
des gardiens de la paix, à coup
sûr.
C'est cette majorité, et vous ne
l'avez pas voté, qui a augmenté de
50% la formation continue des
policiers.
C'est cette majorité, et vous ne
l'avez pas voté, qui a mis dans la
loi que lorsqu'un policier ou un
gendarme était responsable de
violences conjugales ou avait eu
des propos racistes ou xénophobes,
il devait être exclu de la
fonction publique.
Monsieur le député, soyez
constructif.
Aidez-nous.
Soyez aussi honnête.
C'est la majorité socialiste qui a
voté la loi de février 2017.
C'est la majorité socialiste qui,
dans des circonstances difficiles,
s'est rendu compte que les
policiers et les gendarmes, car à
l'époque il y avait sans doute une
gauche républicaine aux
responsabilités, devaient pouvoir
être tous les jours face à ceux
qui voulaient tuer du flic.
Doit-on jeter aux chiens tous les
autres policiers de France lorsque
l'un d'entre eux a fauté?
Vous dites tous les jours qu'il
faut arrêter l'émotion.
Ca vaut aussi pour les citoyens et
pour les policiers.
- Benjamin Lucas: C'est parce que
nous voulons accompagner les
fonctionnaires de police que nous
pointons votre responsabilité,
celle des gouvernements successifs
et des responsables politiques
dans une organisation du maintien
de l'ordre qui conduit à plus de
morts qu'ailleurs en Europe.
Pouvez-vous nier que dans ma
circonscription, à
Mantes-la-Jolie, où 150 lycéens
ont été alignés les mains sur la
tête, il n'y a pas de violences
policières?
Pouvez-vous le nier devant un
jeune qui est contrôlé six à sept
fois plus à cause de la couleur de
sa peau?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
Monsieur le ministre?
- Gérald Darmanin: Monsieur le
député, j'écoute les habitants et
les élus, par exemple de
Mantes-la-Jolie, où je me suis
rendu.
Le maire réclame plus de
policiers.
Oui, monsieur le député.
Moi qui suis issu d'une ville
populaire, je sais que les
habitants des quartiers populaires
ont besoin de sécurité.
Le nier, c'est les laisser voter
Rassemblement National alors
qu'ils votaient à gauche depuis
longtemps.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Thomas
Ménagé.
- Thomas Ménagé: Comme ceux qui
les ont précédés, Emmanuel Macron
et son gouvernement font une fois
encore la terrible démonstration
de leur incapacité totale à
protéger les Français du chaos qui
frappe le pays.
Le candidat Emmanuel Macron disait
que ce serait lui ou le chaos.
C'est pourtant sa politique qui a
accouché du chaos que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui.
Ma question porte sur l'aspect
économique de ce chaos et
s'adresse au ministre de
l'Economie et des Finances.
Dans la nuit de jeudi à vendredi,
la ville de Montargis a été
victime de véritables scènes de
guerre.
Dans cette commune de 14.000
habitants, pourtant épargnée par
les émeutes de 2005, trois
immeubles ont été détruits,
ravagés par les flammes.
80 commerces ont été vandalisés et
pillés par des hordes de jeunes
racailles.
Plus aucun territoire n'est donc
désormais à l'abri de
l'ensauvagement.
A Montargis, comme dans de
nombreuses petites villes, tout un
tissu commercial est aujourd'hui à
l'arrêt.
Dans un contexte économique
difficile, après la crise
sanitaire et alors que l'inflation
explose, les commerçants ont
besoin de mesures bien plus
ambitieuses que l'annonce du
report de charges et de la
diligence des assurances et des
banques.
Ils attendent des mesures fortes
pour indemniser des pertes des
périodes où ils ont dû fermer pour
leur sécurité mais aussi les
pertes à cause de la baisse de
fréquentation qui touche les
commerçants des centres-villes
concernés.
Nos commerçants en ont ras le bol.
Ils sont en colère.
Comprenez leur ras-le-bol.
La colère de ceux qui se lèvent
tôt pour aller travailler, qui
font vivre nos centres-bourgs,
monsieur le ministre, que
comptez-vous faire pour venir en
aide aux commerçants et éviter ce
nouveau chaos économique dans nos
territoires?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Bruno Le
Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Monsieur le
député Ménagé, en cinq jours, ce
sont plus de 1000 commerces qui
ont été saccagés, pillés et, pour
certains, incendiés.
Tous ces actes, sans exception,
sont inqualifiables,
injustifiables et inexcusables.
J'étais ce matin à Arpajon avec la
ministre en charge des PME, Olivia
Grégoire, et nous avons ressenti
l'émotion profonde des
commerçants.
Nous n'avons jamais laissé tomber
les entrepreneurs tout au long des
crises que nous avons traversées.
Nous ne les laisserons jamais
tomber.
Cela fait trois jours que nous
négocions avec les assureurs des
demandes précises.
Les assureurs y ont répondu.
Ils étendront le délai de dépôt de
plainte et de demande
d'indemnisation.
Ils permettront des réductions de
franchise pour les commerçants
indépendants les plus touchés et
apporteront des réponses simples
et rapides à l'ensemble des
commerçants.
S'agissant de l'Etat, j'ai annoncé
que nous étions prêts à reporter
et à alléger les charges sociales
et fiscales.
Pour les cas les plus graves, à
Montargis ou ailleurs, nous
annulerons les dettes sociales et
fiscales des commerçants touchés.
Je tiens à dire que la première
demande de tous les commerçants,
partout sur le territoire qui,
aujourd'hui, sont inquiets, ont
peur pour leur activité, c'est la
fermeté, c'est la sécurité.
C'est ce à quoi s'emploient le
ministre de l'Intérieur et le
ministre de la Justice.
Le gouvernement veut rétablir
partout sur le territoire
l'autorité de l'Etat.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Naïma Moutchou.
- Naïma Moutchou: Madame la
Première ministre, quand les
parents s'habituent à laisser
faire leurs enfants, quand les
enfants n'écoutent plus leurs
paroles, quand les enseignants
tremblent et préfèrent les
flatter, quand ces enfants ne
reconnaissent plus l'autorité,
alors, c'est là le début de la
tyrannie, disait Platon dans "La
République".
La violence de ces derniers jours,
elle est symptomatique d'une
France qui va mal, traversée par
une crise d'autorité et
d'identité.
Ces violences ne seront pas sans
conséquence.
Nous devons rétablir l'ordre.
Mais il ne sert à rien de réparer
ce qui a été abîmé si c'est pour
voir le chaos se reproduire.
La responsabilité d'une partie de
la classe politique dans ce qui se
passe est immense.
C'est une partie de la gauche qui
a nourri chez les jeunes de
quartier le sentiment
d'ostracisation, la haine de la
police et de l'autorité.
L'atmosphère d'une société qui
serait fondamentalement raciste.
Je vous le dis car je l'ai vu à
l'oeuvre.
Je l'ai entendu dire, dans ma
petite cité HLM du Val-d'Oise.
Cette partie de la gauche n'a
laissé aucune chance à ces
populations pour espérer faire
nation.
Pire, elle pense aujourd'hui tirer
un bénéfice politique du désordre,
mais finit par battre en retraite
car elle ne maîtrise rien.
A la fin, ce sont ses meilleurs
ennemis qui essayent d'en tirer
parti, ses meilleurs ennemis de
l'extrême droite.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Madame la
députée, vous faites à travers
votre question un panel de ce qui
a pu éventuellement provoquer les
scènes de violence auxquelles nous
avons assisté.
Vous reliez cela à des questions
politiques.
Je rappelle d'abord l'action du
gouvernement depuis le premier
jour.
1: restaurer l'ordre.
2: maintenir l'ordre.
3: ne jamais perdre de vue
l'objectif de garder l'ordre pour
les territoires.
Les premières victimes sont les
commerçants, ce sont les pompiers,
les gendarmes, les policiers et
les habitants des quartiers qui
ont vu les services publics
incendiés, les magasins éventrés,
et qui se sentent eux-mêmes
victimes de l'image que ces jeunes
ont pu renvoyer des quartiers.
Il y a 4000 personnes qui ont été
interpellées.
Beaucoup comparaissent devant la
justice.
D'autres le seront dans les
prochains jours.
Il serait intéressant de regarder
à qui nous avons affaire.
A quel moment des jeunes de 12 ans
peuvent se retrouver au milieu de
la nuit, un bidon d'essence à la
main, mettre le feu à un pavillon?
Il y a la question de la
responsabilité parentale.
Je ne crois pas qu'il faille
chercher dans les cris une réponse
toute faite.
Nous avons besoin d'apprendre pour
que ça ne se reproduise plus.
La réponse ne sera pas dans un
déferlement de réponse publique
dans ces quartiers.
Il nous faudra saisir les tenants
et aboutissants.
Comment des jeunes de cet âge-là
ont pu en arriver à cela?
De façon plus politique, les
habitants des quartiers concernés
auxquels vous faites allusion
n'ont peut-être pas de parti
politique.
Ils se souviendront tôt ou tard de
qui était là pour restaurer
l'ordre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Nadège Abomangoli.
- Nadège Abomangoli: Il faut être
présent, sinon on n'est pas
parent, a dit le président de la
République.
De nouveau du mépris de classe.
Au lieu d'apaiser, vous rejetez la
faute sur les autres, sur les
faibles, et vous les humiliez.
Vous humiliez depuis des années
ces parents qui se battent pour
leurs enfants, ces parents
applaudis pendant la crise du
Covid et insultés aujourd'hui.
Ignominie supplémentaire, le
président du MEDEF déclare que le
premier employeur en
Seine-Saint-Denis est le trafic de
drogue.
Quel mensonge!
Quelle honte!
Vous insultez ma mère, femme de
ménage.
Vous insultez les personnes qui
courent les brocantes pour acheter
des livres d'école.
Vous humiliez ces parents d'un
collège de Bondy qui se battent
contre les fermetures de classe.
Que leur promettez-vous?
Une justice expéditive pour leur
fils qui ne répare rien et abîme
les vies.
Et pour ces parents jugés
indignes, des sanctions.
Les vieilles recettes de l'extrême
droite, en somme.
Ce n'est pas la voix de
l'apaisement et de la
réconciliation, c'est de la folie.
Il y a des territoires perdus de
la République?
Non.
Il y a des territoires abandonnés
par la République.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Eric
Dupond-Moretti.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Ce discours
est absolument surréaliste.
En réalité, vous injuriez toutes
les femmes de ménage qui ont bien
élevé leurs enfants.
Et ne vous en déplaise, en
particulier la mienne.
Moi, je n'ai jamais traîné dans
les rues à 11 ans.
Et puis, naturellement, vous
n'avez pas entendu le discours
nuancé que nous tenions.
Bien sûr qu'il y a des parents qui
font beaucoup avec peu, mais il y
a des parents qui ne font rien
avec beaucoup.
Ce sont ceux-là que nous visons.
J'ai toujours dit que la maman qui
travaille la nuit pour élever sa
famille ne pouvait pas être
incriminée, mais en revanche, les
parents qui laissent traîner leurs
mômes de 11 ans dans les rues
alors qu'ils devraient être chez
eux, à leur domicile, ils méritent
qu'on les rappelle à leurs
responsabilités.
Vous êtes la France incendiaire!
Incendiaire!
A force de dire que les policiers
sont des meurtriers, que la
justice ne vaut rien, qu'on peut
aller impunément cramer des
commissariats et des tribunaux,
vous donnez un merveilleux exemple
aux enfants dont vous voudriez
vous faire les défenseurs.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Madame la
députée?
- Nadège Abomangoli: Monsieur le
ministre, personne n'aime les
missionnaires armés.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Paul Molac.
- Paul Molac: Ma question concerne
les zones tendues en matière de
logement.
Pas une semaine ne passe sans que
je sois interpellé par les
difficultés à se loger.
La situation a été critique.
En Bretagne, une seule zone
tendue: l'agglomération de Nantes.
Nous dotons les municipalités
d'outils pour éviter la
surtaxation des résidences
secondaires, l'application d'une
taxe sur les logements vacants ou
la possibilité d'encadrement des
loyers.
Pour la liste des communes en zone
tendue dévoilée par le
gouvernement, elle me semble trop
restrictive.
2600 communes seulement sont
concernées.
En Bretagne, 140 communes seraient
La pression immobilière se fait
sentir partout.
La région Bretagne avait demandé à
ce que toute la région soit placée
en zone tendue.
L'exclusion de certaines communes
nous interroge.
Envisagez-vous de revoir votre
copie et d'étendre au-delà de 2600
communes initialement ciblées le
périmètre des zones tendues?
Nous avons besoin d'outils
concrets pour lutter contre les
problèmes de logement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le député.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Klein, ministre chargé de la Ville
et du Logement.
- Olivier Klein: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le député Paul Molac,
vous l'avez rappelé, la
modification du zonage et de la
taxe sur les locaux vacants et la
taxe d'habitation sur les
résidences secondaires est une
mesure forte de la dernière loi de
finances 2023.
C'est l'issue d'un travail des
parlementaires et le travail sur
l'élaboration de la liste vient de
se terminer.
3693 communes ont été choisies.
C'est le fruit d'un travail de
qualité entre le gouvernement et
les associations d'élus.
Pour ces communes choisies, ça va
permettre aux maires d'appliquer
ou pas cette taxe sur les locaux
vacants et cette taxe
d'habitation.
Cela permettra aux maires
d'appliquer la possibilité d'agir
sur les locations touristiques.
C'est une décision de la
collectivité locale et cela doit
le rester.
Avec mes collègues Olivia Grégoire
et Dominique Faure, nous animons
une commission de travail qui va
se réunir le 18 juillet pour
continuer à travailler sur
l'attribution des zones tendues.
Il y a un vrai problème en zone
littorale et en zone de montagne
pour que les habitants de ces
territoires trouvent à se loger.
Une soixantaine de mesures sont en
cours d'examen.
Elles vous ont déjà été
présentées.
Nous allons arbitrer ensemble les
mesures qui nous sembleront les
plus efficaces pour continuer à
travailler dessus.
Il faut que chacun prenne en
compte dans le même temps cette
nécessité de construire partout et
pour l'ensemble des types de
logement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
député?
- Paul Molac: Nous sommes d'accord
sur le fond.
Sur le nombre de communes, il est
important qu'on puisse ouvrir
cette panoplie d'outils au plus
grand nombre.
Aujourd'hui, dans une zone qui
n'est pas très touristique, il y a
des gens qui doivent aller au
camping parce qu'ils ne trouvent
pas de logement près de leur
travail.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Nadia Hai.
- Nadia Hai: Monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur, le mardi 27 juin
au matin, nous découvrions avec
horreur la mort du jeune Nahel par
le tir d'un policier, suscitant
une émotion immense dans tout le
pays, jusqu'au président de la
République.
Le même mardi soir, nos
concitoyens découvrent avec
terreur la destruction et le
saccage organisé en nombre de nos
villes, suscitant la colère de nos
habitants.
Face à la destruction inacceptable
de leurs écoles, de leurs mairies,
de leurs transports, de leurs
services publics, de leurs
hôpitaux, de leurs commerces, dans
ces moments de crise, l'heure
n'est ni à l'analyse, ni aux
propositions farfelues.
L'heure est à la fermeté.
Tolérance zéro face à ces actes
inacceptables.
C'est pourquoi je salue l'action
de la justice.
Je me joins aussi à l'hommage
appuyé à nos forces de l'ordre et
aux pompiers qui ont été mis à
rude épreuve pour nous protéger.
Hommage avec la même force aux
élus, ainsi qu'à ces mamans qui
ont relayé l'appel au calme.
Hommage aussi à ces jeunes qui ont
pris la parole pour condamner ces
actes et s'en désolidariser,
déjouant ainsi les plans
d'instrumentalisation de ceux qui
voulaient utiliser les jeunes des
quartiers comme un bouclier à leur
projet politique, essayant
péniblement de masquer la trahison
de la gauche vis-à-vis de nos
quartiers.
Honte à ceux qui ne se sont pas
levés pour l'appel au calme, à
ceux qui profitent de l'occasion
pour nourrir leur haine.
Monsieur le ministre, vous êtes un
enfant des quartiers, tout comme
moi.
Nous appelons à ce que
l'agissement d'un seul policier ne
jette pas le discrédit sur toute
notre police nationale qui nous
protège et qui nous honore, tout
comme nous appelons à ce que la
conduite inexcusable d'une
minorité des quartiers jette le
discrédit sur l'ensemble des
jeunes de nos quartiers
populaires.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, madame la députée.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin, ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Madame la députée, est-ce que ce
jour-là, à Nanterre, lors de ce
drame qui a touché ce jeune
conducteur, le ministère de
l'Intérieur, les autorités de
l'Etat ont menti sur ce qu'il
s'est passé?
La réponse est non.
Est-ce que ce jour-là, le policier
qui est l'auteur de ce coup de
feu, a été interpellé et mis en
garde à vue?
La réponse est oui.
Est-ce que ce jour-là, après
étude, comme tout citoyen en a le
droit, il a été mis en examen?
Oui.
Il a été déféré devant un juge
d'instruction.
Des chefs d'inculpation de meurtre
ont été ouverts.
Il n'y a pas deux types de
justice.
Il n'y a pas la justice pour les
puissants, pour les agents publics
des forces de l'ordre, et pour les
autres citoyens.
Tous ceux qui colportent le
mensonge sapent l'état de droit,
tous ceux qui déforment la vérité
comme vous l'avez fait, vous, élus
de La France Insoumise, avec
abjection et avec sans doute la
délectation de voir ces révoltes,
ces commerces pillés, ces mairies
brûlées, ces écoles où les enfants
ne pourront plus aller, ces élus
dont l'adresse a été mise sur des
sites Internet pour appeler à la
vengeance, alors, oui, il y a deux
types de comportement: ceux qui
sont républicains, qui respectent
l'état de droit, qui respectent la
déontologie en premier et ceux qui
choisissent le chaos pour mieux
pousser leurs forces politiques.
Nous devons travailler avec toute
la nation et distinguer le bon
grain de l'ivraie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Emeline
K/Bidi.
- Emeline K/Bidi: Merci.
Mes chers collègues, ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre et concerne la cagnotte
de soutien au policier qui a tué
Nahel.
En cinq jours, cette cagnotte
atteint déjà plus d'un million
d'euros, mais bien plus que son
montant, c'est son existence qui
me choque, et plus encore, les
silences assourdissants du
gouvernement à son sujet.
Dans ce moment de crise que
traverse notre pays, nous vous
avons entendue appeler à la
responsabilité des parents, exiger
de la justice la plus grande
fermeté, multiplier les
interpellations, mais s'agissant
de la cagnotte, vous avez
timidement annoncé qu'elle ne
contribuait pas à l'apaisement.
C'est peu dire.
Voilà une cagnotte créée par un
membre de l'extrême droite qui
organise une récolte de fonds pour
aider le meurtrier d'un mineur.
Ne voyez-vous rien de choquant, de
profondément immoral,
manifestement illégale à
l'existence de cette cagnotte?
Pourtant, on se souvient de votre
vive réaction à propos de la
cagnotte qui avait été créée pour
Christophe Dettinger.
Cette cagnotte avait été appelée à
la fermeture.
Vous déclariez à l'époque: "Le
succès de cette opération est
choquante.
Est-ce normal de vouloir soutenir
ce monsieur qu'on a vu frapper un
policier?"
Aujourd'hui, c'est vous qui avez
perdu vos repères.
Un jeune a perdu la vie.
N'est-ce pas moins choquant à vos
yeux?
Si ce n'est au nom de la
morale, agissez au moins au nom du
droit.
Qu'attendez-vous pour le faire?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Madame la députée, je me suis
exprimé sur cette question il y a
quelques instants.
La Première ministre en a parlé
également il y a 48 heures.
Non, ce n'est pas au pouvoir
exécutif de se substituer aux
décisions judiciaires.
Dans le cas précis que vous
évoquez, dans la même expression
du gouvernement, il appartient,
comme c'était le cas lorsque cette
personne avait attaqué un
policier, il appartient au
tribunal d'appliquer le Code civil
et de faire fermer cette cagnotte.
Je voudrais cependant dire ici, et
sans soutenir quoi que ce soit,
que si on pouvait respecter deux
principes: d'abord le principe de
pondération.
Le pays n'est-il pas déjà assez
éruptif?
Il ne faut pas utiliser chaque
prétexte pour faire de la
politique politicienne.
Deuxièmement, y compris ce
policier qui a été mis en examen,
qui a été mis en garde à vue et
qui est en détention provisoire,
ce policier, comme toutes les
personnes qui n'ont pas été
condamnées définitivement par la
justice, il a le droit à la
présomption d'innocence.
Si nous respectons cet équilibre,
nous rappelons que ce n'est pas le
ministre de l'Intérieur qui décide
de la justice.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
- Emeline K/Bidi: Je vois qu'il y
a deux poids, deux mesures.
Dans l'affaire précédente, madame
Elisabeth Borne et madame Marlène
Schiappa ne s'étaient pas gênée pour
dire que cette cagnotte était une
honte.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Justine
Gruet pour le groupe Les
Républicains.
- Justine Gruet: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre,
depuis plusieurs jours, la France
offre aux yeux du monde un bien
triste visage.
Des images de violences urbaines
inacceptables.
Du Jura jusqu'à la tentative
d'assassinat du maire de
L'Hay-les-Roses, je souhaite
témoigner de mon soutien à son
égard, à sa femme et à ses
enfants.
Son engagement au quotidien reste
remarquable et doit être salué,
tout comme doit l'être l'immense
courage de nos pompiers, de nos
gendarmes, de nos policiers
nationaux et municipaux qui sont
les gardiens de la paix et de
l'ordre républicain.
Etre élu, c'est prendre ses
responsabilités.
Lorsque l'ordre est menacé dans
notre pays, les sanctions doivent
tomber.
Agir, c'est mieux.
Les forces de l'ordre sont
confrontées à des émeutiers de
plus en plus jeunes, entre 14 et
18 ans, et de plus en plus
déterminé.
C'est un aveu d'échec en matière
d'éducation et de
responsabilisation des parents
auquel nous ne voulons pas nous
résoudre.
Nous attendons de votre part des
actes forts pour rétablir
l'autorité dans notre pays et
lutter contre la défaillance de
certains parents.
L'heure n'est plus aux paroles
vides et aux demi-mesures en
matière d'éducation.
Il faut passer urgemment à
l'action pour réaffirmer les
valeurs de notre République.
Cela passe par une école forte,
une école qui valorise le goût de
l'effort et le respect du corps
enseignant, mais une école qui ne
se substitue pas aux parents qui
ont des droits et des devoirs.
Notre famille politique avait fait
voter une loi en 2010 qui retirait
une part d'allocations en cas
d'absentéisme à l'école.
Abrogée en janvier 2013 alors que
la gauche était au pouvoir, ma
question est simple: êtes-vous
désormais capables de reprendre
cette mesure et de sanctionner les
parents qui ont démissionné dans
l'éducation de leurs enfants?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Eric
Dupond-Moretti, garde des Sceaux
et ministre de la Justice.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Madame la
députée, je crois que les raisons
qui ont amené à ces violences
absolument inqualifiables,
insupportables, dénoncées par
presque tout le monde ici, ce sont
à l'évidence des raisons
multiples, plurifactorielles.
Ces choses sont très difficiles.
On retrouve des clivages
traditionnels entre ceux qui
disent que rien n'a été fait en
matière de politique de la ville
et d'autres qui disent que des
choses ont été faites, et puis
encore ceux qui disent: "Voilà ce
que nous avons fait."
On peut se poser la question du
respect de nos institutions.
Les choses ne sont pas simples.
J'ai demandé aux procureurs de me
faire remonter leur analyse
précise sur l'âge, mais aussi les
motivations des jeunes que l'on a
retrouvés en train de commettre
des exactions.
Pourquoi?
Il y a un discours simpliste qui
consiste à dire que c'est le
déterminisme.
C'est ce que l'on a entendu tout à
l'heure et que l'on entendra
encore.
C'est un discours de
déresponsabilisation
insupportable.
Je pense tout simplement que ne
mettre en avant que le
déterminisme, c'est nier notre
liberté.
Comme je l'ai dit il y a un
instant, il y a des femmes de
ménage qui élèvent bien leurs
enfants et il y a des enfants qui
ne commettent pas des infractions.
Tout cela reste une question de
nuance.
Je voudrais redire, à la place qui
est la mienne, que Gérald Darmanin
et moi, nous assumons la réponse
que nous avons apportée en
personnel, et nous rendons hommage
évidemment aux policiers,
gendarmes, aux pompiers, aux
magistrats, aux greffiers qui ont
été au rendez-vous de nos
obligations.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
C'est fini.
Merci beaucoup, monsieur le
ministre.
La parole est à madame Blandine
Brocard pour le groupe démocrate.
- Blandine Brocard: Merci.
Madame la ministre chargée des PME
et du Commerce, on est abasourdis.
"C'est toute une vie qui
s'arrête."
Ce sont les mots des très nombreux
commerçants pillés ces derniers
jours partout en France.
Je souhaite ici porter leur voix,
la voix de ceux qui sont le coeur
de nos centres-villes, de nos
quartiers.
La plupart d'entre eux souffraient
déjà de la désaffection liée à la
concurrence de la vente à
distance.
Puis, il y a eu les gilets jaunes
et le Covid.
Enfin, une respiration, mais non.
Le saccage et les pillages de ces
derniers jours sont venus ruiner
le gagne-pain de nos commerçants,
qui voient leur travail détruit,
anéanti sous leurs yeux.
Au final, ce sont plus d'un
milliard d'euros de dégâts.
Quid de l'impact sur le tourisme
au début de cette période
estivale?
En 2022, l'assurance multirisque a
augmenté de 10%.
En 2023, de 8%.
Combien pour l'année prochaine?
Seul 1 commerçant sur 2 souscrit
une assurance perte
d'exploitation.
Il faudra également payer les
franchises immédiatement, il
faudra payer les employés.
Il faudra également payer de
nouveaux aménagements pour tenter
de sécuriser toujours plus son
commerce.
Face à ce désarroi profond, l'Etat
doit répondre présent.
Aussi, comment pouvons-nous
prévoir l'accélération des
procédures de permis de
reconstruire pour les magasins
détruits?
Au-delà du soutien financier, la
rapidité des réponses à apporter
est essentielle et il en va
évidemment de même du côté des
assureurs.
Pour toutes celles et ceux dont
l'outil de travail a été saccagé,
leur laissant un sentiment de vide
et de vie détruite, pouvez-vous
nous détailler les mesures que
vous prendrez pour soutenir nos
commerçants et leur permettre de
travailler?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Olivia
Grégoire, ministre déléguée
chargée des PME, de l'artisanat et
du commerce.
- Olivia Grégoire: Merci.
Merci de vos mots, madame la
députée Brocard, à l'endroit des
commerçants, et notamment des
commerçants indépendants qui, au
nombre d'un millier à peu près,
ont été touchés par les émeutes.
Je vous remercie aussi d'avoir
répété leurs mots.
J'ai eu l'occasion d'être à leurs
côtés ce matin à Arpajon, et hier
à Paris, dans le 15e
arrondissement.
Avant même de parler de demain, je
pense qu'il est très important de
prendre la mesure de leur état
psychologique.
Je tiens à vous dire que dans
chaque préfecture de France, les
conseillers, à chaque sortie de
crise, sont mobilisés pour bien
sûr accompagner les étalements de
charge, voir les annulations de
dettes fiscales des commerçants
les plus touchés, mais je veux
aussi dire que les conseils
départementaux à la sortie de
crise peuvent accompagner
moralement les commerçants qui
sont les plus sidérés.
Je crois que le mot qui
fonctionne, c'est la sidération.
Pour ce qui est de demain, nous
avons déjà réuni à plusieurs
reprises avec Bruno Le Maire, à la
demande de la Première ministre,
les assureurs et les banquiers.
Nous leur avons demandé que ce
soit rapide et simple.
Pour que ce soit plus rapide, on
va aussi laisser le temps à la
sidération de passer.
Il faut plusieurs jours pour
qu'elle passe.
Les commerçants n'auront pas cinq
jours, mais 30 jours pour se
retourner vers leur assureur.
Nous aurons, dans les semaines qui
viennent, le président vient de
l'annoncer, une loi qui va porter
la question des délais pour la
reconstruction à la fois sur le
volet des communes qui ont été
touchées, mais aussi pour
accompagner les commerçants et
pour que ça se fasse le plus vite
possible.
Dans le doute, il y a deux
réflexes à avoir, très simples.
Premièrement: porter plainte.
Deuxièmement: appeler son
assureur.
Je me permets de rappeler ces
évidences qui sont majeures.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur François
Piquemal pour le groupe La France
Insoumise.
- François Piquemal: Madame la
Première ministre, la mort du
jeune Nahel, tué par un policier,
montre à quel point il convient de
changer la doctrine de la police.
C'était une des propositions du
plan présenté par Jean-Louis
Borloo en 2018.
Sur le transport, la petite
enfance, l'emploi, les moyens pour
les communes, la lutte contre les
discriminations, ce plan était
issu de l'appel de Grigny qui
réunissait des élus locaux, des
maires qui travaillaient sur un
rapport dont le nom fait écho
aujourd'hui, "Vivre en grand,
vivre ensemble la République pour
une réconciliation nationale".
19 grandes mesures que nous
pourrions discuter.
Qu'en a fait monsieur Macron?
Il l'a jeté à la poubelle avec
mépris et arrogance.
Tout le monde ici s'en souvient.
Depuis, quelle vision pour les
quartiers prioritaires de la
ville?
Aucune.
Dans ces quartiers comme ailleurs,
vous avez dégradé les services
publics par vos politiques en
matière de santé, d'éducation, de
justice, de logement, de vie
associative.
La force d'une nation, c'est la
cohésion.
Comme le dit si bien le maire de
Trappes à propos de ceux qui
refusent de construire du logement
social dans leur commune: "Ceux
qui croient pouvoir rester entre
riches et qui croient que leur
bonheur individuel ne sera jamais
heurté par un malheur collectif
organisé dans nos banlieues se
trompent lourdement."
Ils seront tôt ou tard rattrapés,
comme tout le monde l'est
aujourd'hui.
Il existe des ghettos de riches.
Il faut en finir avec le
séparatisme de ces derniers et
faire respecter aussi la loi de la
République.
Quelles seront donc vos mesures
pour assurer cette cohésion, pour
remettre du droit commun et des
services publics de qualité
partout dans nos quartiers?
Rappelons que les habitants de ces
derniers font partie des
essentiels qui rapportent plus à
la société qu'ils ne perçoivent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Klein.
- Olivier Klein: Merci.
Monsieur le député, d'abord,
permettez-moi à mon tour d'avoir
évidemment une pensée pour Nahel,
une pensée pour les
sapeurs-pompiers, pour toutes les
forces de sécurité qui ont
travaillé d'arrache-pied ces
derniers jours, une pensée pour
les élus et une pensée pour
l'ensemble des fonctionnaires et
les habitants de ces quartiers
populaires.
Pour ce qui est du plan Borloo, si
vous le regardiez avec attention,
vous verriez que c'est une partie
de l'inspiration de l'action du
gouvernement lors du quinquennat
précédent.
Je veux rappeler les cités
éducatives, dont le président a
annoncé son extension sur
l'ensemble des villes en politique
de la ville.
Vous avez dit que l'ANRU ne
servait à rien il y a quelques
jours dans la presse.
Lorsque nous avons pris la
direction de cette décision, il y
avait 5 milliards pour l'ANRU.
Il y a aujourd'hui 12 milliards.
L'ANRU, c'est aujourd'hui plus de
1500 chantiers partout en France,
parmi les 453 territoires en
quartiers.
Ce chantier est extrêmement
important.
Le plan Borloo, c'est moins
d'enfants dans l'école.
Le plan Borloo, c'est plus de
culture dans les quartiers
populaires,
et c'est extrêmement important
pour les enfants des quartiers.
C'est aussi l'ouverture des
bibliothèques, le plan Borloo.
Le gouvernement a accompagné
également les bibliothèques.
Le plan Borloo a été mis en
oeuvre...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Denis
Masséglia pour le groupe
Renaissance.
- Denis Masséglia: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre,
l'incompréhension nous frappe tous
depuis une semaine.
L'incompréhension tout d'abord,
face au drame terrible qui est
survenu à Nanterre et qui a coûté
la vie au jeune Nahel.
A ses proches, je redis notre
confiance à la justice pour faire
la lumière sur ce drame.
L'incompréhension ensuite,
vis-à-vis des troubles auxquels
nous assistons depuis plusieurs
nuits et face auxquels nos forces
de l'ordre sont plus que jamais
engagées.
Une colère aveugle semble s'être
emparée de tout le territoire, non
seulement dans les grandes villes,
mais aussi dans les villes moins
denses, d'habitude plus calmes.
J'en veux pour preuve la ville de
Cholet, 56.000 habitants
confrontés pour la première fois à
une telle violence.
Je comprends la colère quand ils
dénoncent la difficulté du
quotidien, mais je refuse de
comprendre la violence gratuite.
Je refuse de comprendre que les
associations retrouvent les pneus
de leurs véhicules crevés, que les
commerçants découvrent leurs
magasins pillés et que les élus
soient attaqués jusque chez eux.
Cholet, ce n'est ni une zone
urbaine très dense, ni la
ruralité.
Cholet, c'est une ville moyenne où
il fait bon vivre, où le taux de
chômage est de 4,6%, où les
entreprises ne demandent qu'à
embaucher.
Cholet, c'est une ville moyenne
comme il en existe tant en France
et dont les habitants ne
comprennent pas qu'une minorité
saccage, brûle, attaque.
Sur ces territoires, il ne manque
pourtant pas de sujets pour
lesquels se mobiliser avec
conviction, mais dans le respect.
Je pense par exemple au manque de
médecins, au manque de forces de
l'ordre.
C'est là que doit se concentrer
notre énergie d'élus et
l'accompagnement des pouvoirs
publics.
Que répondre aux millions de
Français qui vivent dans ces
territoires, confrontés
quotidiennement à des difficultés
structurelles et à ce sentiment de
délaissement?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu, ministre de la
Transition écologique de la
transition des territoires.
- Christophe Béchu: Merci.
Monsieur le député, il y a 553
communes à la minute où nous
parlons qui, depuis le milieu de
la semaine dernière, ont connu des
dégradations.
Il y a celles auxquelles on pense,
qui ont fait la une de la presse,
parce qu'il y a eu des événements
d'une gravité particulière, il y a
les grandes villes, les quartiers
politiques de la ville, et puis il
y a une géographie nouvelle dont
on n'a pas l'habitude.
Dans ces 553 communes, il y en a
170 qui n'ont pas un quartier
politique de la ville et dans
lesquelles les explications et les
raccourcis ne sauraient expliquer
ce qu'on a vécu.
Dans les autres, nous en avons 120
dans lesquelles les habitants qui
vivent en quartier politique de
la ville sont moins de 3000 dans
les communes dont nous parlons.
Le temps de l'analyse, la volonté
du président de la République de
faire en sorte de prendre le temps
de regarder les choses, de
regarder aussi quels sont
les profils de ces
4000 émeutiers qui ont été
interpellés, au-delà de leur
moyenne d'âge, de leur jeunesse.
Pour être très concret, Cholet est
un bon exemple d'une ville qui est
dans le top 100 des communes où il
fait bon vivre, une commune dans
laquelle il n'y a pas de
difficultés de ce type.
Est-ce que c'est lié à la haine
contre les institutions?
Est-ce que c'est le prétexte qui
permet de commettre de tels actes?
Derrière votre question, il y a la
grande interrogation qui devrait
véritablement nous interroger
au-delà du brouhaha: prendre les
quelques minutes, non pas pour que
chacun ressorte de la boîte le
rapport dont il pense qu'il est la
solution, la proposition qu'il
avait faite lors de la dernière
présidentielle, mais au contraire,
regarder les yeux dans les yeux ce
dont nous avons besoin
aujourd'hui.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Marine Le
Pen, présidente du groupe
Rassemblement National.
- Marine Le Pen: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
Au moment où notre pays vient
d'être livré au saccage, au
pillage et à une rage incendiaire
insensée, je voudrais vous poser
la question que se posent tous les
Français: qu'avez-vous fait de la
France?
Vous qui menez la même politique
que vos prédécesseurs depuis 40
ans, qu'avez-vous fait de notre
pays en y implantant des zones de
non-droit que vous avez laissées
se communautariser et se
criminaliser?
Qu'avez-vous fait pour
transformer notre pays parmi les
plus courtois, les plus élégants
et les plus doux de la terre, pour
en faire un enfer?
Notre pays qui fut admiré pour son
rayonnement culturel et sa
puissance, suscite aujourd'hui la
pitié quand ce n'est pas l'ironie.
Vous n'avez tiré aucune leçon des
émeutes de 2005, pas plus du Stade
de France, ce qui laisse augurer
un désastre sécuritaire pour les
JO de 2024 et avec lui, une
nouvelle humiliation nationale.
La vérité, c'est que vous n'avez
voulu entendre aucun
avertissement.
Ce qui arrive, nous l'avions
prédit malgré une grande
adversité.
Je le dis avec tristesse et
gravité, nous avions eu raison.
Je vous appelle au courage de
l'autocritique, à l'humilité
d'admettre l'échec dramatique de
vos politiques.
Il faut d'abord et avant tout
stopper l'immigration anarchique.
Or, vous êtes en train d'aggraver
le problème du communautarisme,
voire du séparatisme et de le
disséminer dans le moindre
village.
Il faut ensuite reprendre la main
dans tous les quartiers de France,
rétablir l'autorité des parents,
refaire de l'école le creuset de
la République, rendre à la justice
sa fermeté sans laquelle elle
restera impuissante à protéger les
Français!
Face au chaos sécuritaire,
économique et judiciaire,
allez-vous enfin admettre que la
seule solution possible est
nationale?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Elisabeth
Borne, Première ministre.
Applaudissements
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la présidente Le Pen, j'ai
écouté avec beaucoup d'attention
votre intervention et j'ai cru un
instant qu'il pourrait y avoir des
propositions, car jusqu'au bout,
vous démontrez une fois de plus la
seule chose dont vous êtes
capable, c'est la caricature.
Même si ça ne me surprend pas
beaucoup, je regrette que le choix
que vous fassiez, c'est celui de
la division.
Quand j'entends le président de
votre parti opposer les
territoires ruraux et les
quartiers comme si aimer les uns
devait dépouiller les autres, je
me dis que décidément, vous n'avez
pas changé.
Quand j'entends encore à l'instant
pointer une certaine partie de
notre population, je me dis que de
nouveau, les caricatures, vous n'y
échapperez pas.
Aujourd'hui, alors que de nombreux
maires vivent des situations
difficiles, alors que des
commerçants et des artisans ont
fait face à beaucoup de violence,
ne pas jouer l'unité du pays, ce
n'est pas responsable, madame la
présidente Le Pen.
Ce n'est pas responsable!
Pour notre part, nous serons
toujours en soutien de nos
policiers, de nos gendarmes, de
nos sapeurs-pompiers, des
policiers municipaux, des élus
locaux.
Nous serons toujours mobilisés
pour lutter contre la violence,
mais nous serons également
mobilisés pour lutter contre le
poison de la division, et quand
notre République est attaquée,
c'est l'unité nationale qui doit
l'emporter.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.